on va plonger France on y va dans dans
vos 500 pages et bien après le sursaut
après la Belle Époque voici le tome 3 de
votre histoire intime de la 5e
République et il est comme toujours
absolument féroce et réjouissant même si
le titre mérite une vraie explication
tragédie française c'est l'histoire d'un
pays qui ne s'aime plus tout simplement
qui n'est plus fier de son histoire la
faute au club des démolisseurs regardez
c'est dans l'invitation de Stéphanie des
piierres et on en parle tous les deux
tranquillement et longuement juste
[Musique]
après si on vous invite franç Olivier
gisberg c'est parce qu'on ne se lasse
pas de votre regard féroce et de votre
plume serrée pour croquer cette classe
politique française que vous avez
étroitement côtoyé vous êtes
éditorialiste au point journaliste radio
télé et patron vous avez dirigé
plusieurs titres et écrit des
biographies voici donc tragédie
française 3è et dernier volume de votre
histoire intime de la 5e République qui
met le souvenir personnel les
confidences des politiques vous essayez
de vous inscrire dans les pas de Château
brillant dans tragédie française le
récit commence en
1981 vous fustigez ce que vous appelez
les sept chevalier du déclin cinq
présidents de la République deux premier
ministres mitéran Chirac baladure Jospin
Sarkozy Holland Macron tous coupables
selon vous d'avoir laissé filer les
déficits et s'opérer un grand
dérèglement migratoire de François
mitteran vous écrivez s'il n'a pas
changé la vie il a au moins réussi à
plomber l'économie shirac est dites-vous
un roi fait néant un président
malheureux et rendu impotant dès le
départ par les grèves de l'automne
1995 à coup de phrases drôles et
méchantes d'anecdotes consigné dans vos
carnets vous dénoncez 40 ans de crise de
la volonté politique de Lionel Jospin
vous dites il a abîmé le pays sans le
faire faire exprès en croyant bien faire
vous confiez vos regrets d'avoir
participé à une campagne anti-Hollande
vous osez rêver d'un tendè Sarkozy
Hollande qui aurait allié leur qualités
il n'y a qu'avec Emmanuel Macron que
vous n'avez pas de lien privilégié
notamment car dès sa campagne en 2017
une de ses déclarations vous fait bondir
il n'y a d'ailleurs pas une culture
française il y a une culture en France
elle est diverse elle est
multiple votre proximité avec ces chefs
d'État aucun ne trouve grâce à vos yeux
alors Fran Olivier Gisbert des se
chevaliers du déclin qui a fait le plus
de mal au pays ah je peux pas répondre à
cette question réponse mais non je peux
pas répondre est le principal
responsable respons mais mitan ça
commence avec lui effectivement mitan a
beaucoup de qualité miteran c'est un
homme d'état vous l'avez admiré
longtemps oui mais toujours toujours
parce qu' l'homme privé était
sensationnel et puis y avait tout toute
une partie de mitteran vous savez sur la
France la façon de voir la France la
géopolitique tout ça il sentaiit bien le
problème c'est l'économ il a plombé
complètement et c'est-à-dire que de GA
av fait un travail formidable 1958 il
remet tout desquer et puis regardez dans
les années 70 la France est un modèle à
l'étranger l'étude de l'son Institute là
tous ces amerloc qui arrivent ici en
France pour regarder c'est là que se
dessine l'avenir du monde c'est
formidable le modèle français ça c'est
dans les années c'est 1970 et et puis en
80 il y a beaucoup d'argent dans les
caisses et on vide tout et on pense
idioe totale on pense qu'en dépensant
plus on va créer de la croissance bah on
a vu le résultat hein et c'est c'était
c'est l'taé l'ffondrement vous lui en
voulez d'ailleurs terriblement pour ça
mais vous épargnez votre ami Pierre
Moroi hein qui a essayé de limiter la
casse je népargne pas pierre Moroi non
non pierre Moroi il a résister il s'est
battu il aimait miteran parce que
miteran c'est quelqu'un qu'on pouvait
aimer donc il il était très loyal mais
en privé avec mitteran avec ses
conseillers il était extrêmement violent
et il a fait la rigueur le célèbre
tournant de la rigueur c'est lui seul
qui l' imposé
d'ailleurs à un moment donné après les
les municipales de 1983 il a dit de
toute façon ben je m'en vais moi je vais
pas faire cette politique idiote on va
pas continuer comme ça et finalement
miter l' écouté alors erreur
fondamentale de la gauche vous en parlez
longuement sur l'économie dénis aussi de
cette gauche sur la question migratoire
vous parlez même d'un terrorisme
intellectuel de la gauche dans cette
scène incroyable où jeandiiel patron du
Nouvel Observateur se fait très
clairement remettre à sa place par
François miteron oui qui lui dit à un
moment donné vous parlez comme Le Pen
parce que évidemment jeananiiel dit mais
attendez ça va poser un problème enfin
c'estàdire il y a ce déni qui est très
très fort et très violent moi-même je je
vois bien dans dans cette époque là je
on vous tombe dessus quand vous en
parlez chance ce qu'on avit pas le droit
de dire non mais c'est c'est vrai que ça
commence cette espèce de chape de plomb
qui va tomber mais sur l'économie aussi
il fallait jamais critiquer je me
souviens qu'est-ce que j'ai pas entendu
pendant quand Jospin a fait cette enfin
Jospin c'est surtout auri d'ailleurs
cette absurde réduction du temps de
travail qui devait créer des emplois pas
un seul emploi rien il y a pas eu un
seul emploi de créer et on et vous savez
les Français sont beaucoup moins cons
que les politiques que les politiques de
l'époque qui ont fait ça ils sont
beaucoup moins bêtes parce que les
Français vous faites tous les sondages
c'est la même chose les Français
très très mauvaise mesur économique mais
on veut pas changer surtout on change
pas parce qu'évidemment bah oui on en
profite tous ça c'est vrai cette cette C
cité de la gauche vous en parlez aussi
sur sur la question de la montée de
l'islamisme que vous situez dans les
années 90 avec les années de plomb
d'ailleurs en Algérie d'ailleurs vous
aussi vous dites j'ai pas compris ah oui
il y a beaucoup de choses que j'ai j'ai
pas voulu croire que la République ne
permettrait pas d'absorber tout ça moi
j'ai toujours cru que tout ça se
passerait assez bien après c'est vrai
que les flots migratoires l'idée de pas
contrôler les flots migratoires parce
c'est un peu comme ça avec tous les
clandestins et cetera tout ça ça
commence dans les années 80 90 c'est
dément ça je le trouve en même temps je
me dis
mais la machine va absorber tout ça mais
aussi parce que je suis très républicain
et je suis partisan de la laïcité vous
savez moi je suis fils de prof ma mère
profe de philo mais c'était qui vous
rendez un très B hommage d'ailleurs oui
mais ma mère était mais c'était dingue
c'est-à-dire la religion n'avait pas le
droit de rentrer elle était câ n'avait
pas le droit de rentrer dans le lycée
péterit les plombs la politique non plus
elle était militant de politique
recardienne enfin elle militait beaucoup
et la politique pas de politique ça
c'est une un autre temps et si vous
voulez ce temps-là alors euh on voyait
bien tout ça commençait à être sapé et
et c'est moi c'est vrai que je croyais
aussi que ça pouvait peut-être marcher
mais en même temps je voulais défendre
cette république elle commençait à
chanceler et là c'est vrai qu'ellec le
dernier président on est rentré dans un
truc qui ressemble un peu au
communautarisme mais mais mais regardez
ce qui se passe ouou mais regardez ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est très
intéressant parce que aujourd'hui on
voit quand on voit ce qui se passe en
Grande-Bretagne on voit très bien que le
modèle républicain qui est très attaqué
y compris par beaucoup de macronistes le
modèle républicain c'est quand même 100
fois mieux que le modèle communautariste
on na pas des foule énorme qui se
candent mort aux Juifs comme ça dans les
dans les rues de Paris c'est quand même
c'est mieux ouais voilà voilà ça va pas
bien du tout en France mais quand on se
comp tout Jacques Chirac dont vous
adoriez la compagnie vous l'avez écrit
euh sur de nombreuses pages sympathiques
aussi sympathique que lâche écrivez-vous
il vous confie après l'abandon de la
réforme des régimes spéciaux en 1995 la
France n'a plus je cite qu'une ambition
rester planté jusqu'à la nuit des temps
à écouter l'herbe poussée lui non plus
n'a fait n'a fait preuve d'aucun courage
politique ah non il était capable de
courage politique non non non non non
nonnational sur l'international sur
l'Irak ça c'est lui on a fait croire que
c'était Villepin mais c'est lui moi j'ai
des conversations d'ailleurs je sais
cite ces phrases mais était d'une
violence absolument incroyable et il
voyait bien parce qu'il sentait très
bien lui son grand problème c'était
l'islamisme on peut pas dire qu'il avait
pas vu le truc venir c'est pour ça qu'il
défendait tous les régimes d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'il défendait Saddam
Hussein c'est pour ça qu'il défendait
Benali bah même s'il a pas trop défendu
sur la fin c'est pour ça qu'il était
très copain aussi avec Mbarak en pour
lui il préférait les dictatures ou le
régime dur parce qu'il disait attention
le vrai danger c'est l'islamisme et il
disait cette guerre bon et puis sur
plein d'autres sujets regardez sur
l'histoire du v je peux enfin il il y a
50 discours de Chirac où on voit quand
même brusquement il se réveill mais
encore l'économie est toujours
l'économie c'est ça alors l'économie
l'économie c'est compliqué Chirac c'est
qu'à un moment donné effectivement il y
a une forme d'abandon on peut pas y
arriver avec ses français voyez avec je
l'entends parler si vous voulez quand
j'entends Chirac et que je relis les
phrases de De Gaulle il y a un peu de ça
on peut rien faire avec ces gens-là
c'est les Français c'est pas oui oui non
non cétait oui le côté comment dire
vantard voyez que un peu lâche tout ce
qu'on lit dans la guerde desig César
voyez que on avance av avance vous avez
cette formule que j'ai trouvé géniale
jusqu'à Sarkozi la droite n'est qu'une
gauche qui aime les agriculteurs et la
police c'est vrai Nicolas Sarkozi va
changer ça ou il essaye il essaye vous
avez toujours autant de haine contre lui
moins qu'avant c'estàdire que
c'est-à-dire que Nicolas Sarkozi j'avoue
que j'étais très violent pendant son son
cacada et quand on prend un peu de recul
moi c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
j'essaie d'être honnête je suis là
avec mal pleine de de dossiers de de
notes que j'avais pris de de journal
même une époque c'est extraordinaire je
te dis mon journal donc tout ça et je
vois très bien j'avais trop de passion
et en fait il a essayé bon il a été
bloqué dans plein d'endroits mais enfin
il a quand même fait quelque chose
quelques petites choses disons vous le
reconnaissez quand on se souvient la
dendure que vous aviez contre lui vous
avez quelques pages pour dire au moins
en temps de crise il était il était là
il était très bon il faut dire sur la
crise
financièrees bon il a beaucoup endetté
la France à cette occasion mais quand
même il a évité des catastres surt il a
mené non non puis il a mené la stratégie
internationale ENF on voit très bien
regarder sur l'Europe parce qu'en fait
on a tout de suite été impacté par cette
crise tout de suite on ne sait pas
d'ailleurs c'est en travaillant sur C je
m'en suis rendu compte l'histoire de
tout de suite qui est arrivé avec la BNP
c'était un truc c'était c'était nous
quoi ouais et il a réussi ça notamment
avec avec Angela Merkel François
Hollande pour qui vous aviez de l'estime
au départ vous déçois profondément il y
a cette scène qui peine incroyable he
franchement il faut la lire et la relire
on s'est dit c'est pas possible plein de
témoins euh vous lui pr vous lui
prédisez devant témoins la fin de son
quinena ta présidence est foutue alors
que tu crois qu'elle vient de commencer
raconte-nous oui en fa une scène c'était
à l'Élysée une remise de de prix et
cetera et je voyais pendant le comme
j'étais dans le jury j'étais là tout
près je voyais qu'il me regardais tout
le temps je me suis dit
merde je sais affronter les choses
effectivement dès que le truc est
terminé il fonde sur moi et il gueule
enfin par ou parce qu'il était très très
énervé contre vos une avec la montre à
l'enversit que j'avais fait qui étaient
horrible des photos qui étaient pas
sympa des titres qui étaient alors on se
réveille alors on continue avec les
bêtises enfin voyez ce genre de truc
très violent quoi et et et c'est le
point qui avait commencé d'ailleurs
alors que après la presse a suivit parce
qu'il voyait que ça marchait très bien
mais moi j'étais assez énervé parce que
je dis mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait voyez
il arrive au pouvoir et il fait rien or
on sait très bien que la si on veut
changer un pays il faut le faire dans
les 100 premiers jours et et donc il
commence à me gueuler dessus et je lu
réponds mais oui effectivement je ce que
vous avez dit c'est-à-dire oui maisce
qui vous répond finalement la main sur
l'épaule je vais vous dire et c'est là
qu'on voit c'est il est très intelligent
non non mais il est très intelligent je
souviens Olivier d'assau qui était tout
près qui était là il y avait pas mal de
chefs d'entreprise m'a dit mais ce type
il est quand même il était fasciné
disait par l'intelligence aussi
c'est-à-dire que il met la main sur
l'épaule il me dit je crains que tu
n'aes raison je crains que tu n'es
raison alors il nous reste une Poé de
seconde on va passer sur Emmanuel Macron
d'ailleurs il vous intéresse qu'à moié
vous dites qu'il est narcissique qu'il
se suffit à lui-même vous l'avez pas
vraiment cherché à le à le
rencontrer parce que tout n'est pas
foutu c'est ça qui est
intéressant vous avez quand même un tout
petit peu de d'optimisme pour un sursaut
je vais vous montrer quatre on en CH pe
pas mourir elle est tellement belle non
mais la beauté ne meurt jamais on a
choisi après réflexion avec mon équipe
quatre personnalités qui peuvent avoir
un destin à venir on verra qui sur ces
quatre là Édouard Philip
our Françis Ruff a le bon diagnostic sur
le
payselon vous je pense que d'abordouard
Philipp c'est le candidat des des
journalistes des médias et des
patrons vre non forcément ils sont
toujours plantés ceux ça marche pas en
général c'est regardez dans le passé
c'est et
oublour moi je lui il est pas fait pour
faire la politique c'est un chroniqueur
bon changer de métier en plus faut
jamais changer de métier trop tard il
aurait dû commencer à 30 ans voyez
rabill euh casenav il est sur un bon
créneau c'est quelqu'un tout à fait
intelligent de remarquable je dirais
c'est une personnalité remarquable mais
ça prend pas et pourquoi ça prend pas
parce que je pense qu'il fait pas les
efforts bah il faut qu'il fasse faut
faut qu'il fasse un peu les trataux c
plus le plus jeune le petit dernier vous
intéresse ou pas alors lui il est
intéressant mais euh il faut faire il a
AFF faire à très forte partie parce que
Mélenchon que la presse mort mais non
mais dlenchon il est pas mort Mélenchon
n'est pas mort du tout Mélenchon il a
une stratégie 15 % je veux le vote
musulman et cetera j'agglomère des trucs
autour et à partir de 15 % je suis très
fort donc le la succession de Mélenchon
bah ça peut être qu'une histoire de
santé à un moment donné mais je veux
dire je je pense qu'il est encore là
puis qu'il souhaite se présenter à la
prochaine présidentielle mais bon il
peut attendre c'est dit tragédie
française au singulier personne n'a
vraiment grâce aux yeux
de fr mais pas complètement parce que
vous êtes
t Ro et même
certainirac regardez Chirac en 86 et 88
il a
été
plus plein d'autres il y en a plein
d'autres allez c'est àire
c'està Ren monori
regardez non mais attendez ou je remonte
ça fait rêver je vais vous dire il
fautarrêter sacré bonhomme garagiste
d'accord mais il savait compter allez on
s'arrête là